yeah welcome to this video playing
playing playing playing what something
else the National mass sunlight like
Martha's Martin songs and I'm not quite
sure if he's still playing regular
tournament chess maybe I'm just I don't
know
quite quite good too international
master two for something all the time in
his early 20s if I'm not mistaken okay
we've got an appearance here plate with
c5 and really hope that he's not a super
expert because I have very limited
experience myself okay this is right and
now he's six okay this is also a line
I think you think you take with the
Queen
Wow okay I mean this is the stuff h3e
for yam this is sound this is the
theoretical position
I think no black needs to go night a 67
something like that and even long
castles I mean okay I cannot Castle
short no say no way maybe maybe
immediately
so just 97 or gentle night before us
okay it's kind of Canada according to
plan I mean night before as it looks
very stupid
so not do that okay yes there are some
some point in fixing pawns with f5 for
instance f5 g5 and then you know if I go
v6 he probably plays d6 this look so
looks tricky night b5 whatever might not
be 5 maybe night b5 to deform like that
yeah and if he takes I have fruit d7
later I first of all I'm threatening on
be too if he exchanges that I have rook
d7 now maybe rook d7 Rupert e8 later may
be attacking d5 I always need to be a
bit cautious here with the king I mean
my king is a bit open consider something
like Bishop to d3 and f5 and so on I
came here he actually allows that not
sure if I would have done that if I was
would have been white I think this looks
helpful now at 5 hell oh wait wait wait
there's even g4 hanging hanging okay if
I take g4 it takes is 7 at the text c-5m
this is this is not
not very nice but if I just let's let's
just keep it simple that play is six
yeah this is good
getting rid of this pawn and the the
exchanges takes Queen takes this should
be you should be fine for me I've got a
compact quite compact structure and he's
got these pawns somewhat weak it's not
an advantage for black here but it looks
like I should should be in decent shape
okay don't want to sacrifice the H pawn
my king is in the center this is
something that might be helpful okay
let's just take him asking how how is
going to proceed here yeah
now the question is how ambitious should
I be in this position this is not easy
to say yeah come on take this I mean
it's clear that black is better it's not
so clear how much I think simply because
I have the King in play but maybe I'm
over optimistic I'm always optimistic at
chess it is usually helpful but
sometimes it's it's not so great
King 2d6 maybe
and I didn't think about that
okay this wasn't planned in any anyway
ah
what nonsense you know they can go
rookie one yeah yeah or that
but this is I don't know
no Mike eNOS is really really joining
the action tried to win pawns can he go
here alright cover that the king is an
active active strong piece threatening
kingi for taking taking at the point
check
yeah let's try to win this now it's an
extra point those pants are on dark
squares this is not good news but anyway
I should should try to win yeah this
rupee - on Queen C for King c-45 you
need to be quicker
check yep I hope that time my H porn is
quick what more slip
oh dude just give me a couple of seconds
please
yeah I should have I should manage
actually in three seconds but half what
is funny funny funny mostly okay I can I
can also I can just promote the porn
this is much easier but I know I was a
bit bit too shocked Mary but this was
still happening him yeah wow what a bad
end game I mean I'm just a poor not
really for nothing and I really let him
in again yeah maybe this isn't so clear
I mean I can I can do various things to
try to improve on that they are probably
rupee for us the easiest like to check
this quickly something like this should
be it's maybe the way to go this intense
also see fault
Gallus is good ham
this is good
mm this is probably the way to go is
it's got problems with playing this I
take G 2 and maybe I'm just too quick
yeah this is a very cute idea by the
computer would be to made very strong
actually he needs to do weird things now
we get to to try to continue even stuff
like that him and then you have got the
two pawns yeah this is probably this is
probably good if I just just for some
for simplicity I can I can maybe play
just like this keeping the queenside
intact and then push the pawns yeah ok
thanks for watching